hi
this is a Sadashiva pie from a science
mission today we have dr. Gupta with us
dr. vinet Gupta
so he is the vice chair of voice share
for research and innovation he is also
the director of drug discovery center
dr. Vinay Gupta has he's in the rush
Medical College in Chicago Illinois
so dr. Gupta has published several
articles in various peer-reviewed
journals and he has received several
grants and is in the editorial board of
several journals so welcome dr. Gupta to
science anga thank you so that shape
preciate you are inviting us here thanks
for joining us so tell us about yourself
your background your education how you
got here
yeah good question III have a fairly
simplistic journey up to now so I I was
born in India did my undergraduate work
in Delhi I went to Delhi University and
then I went to IIT Delhi and then
subsequently came here for my graduate
studies I was at University of Rochester
I'm a chemist by training so got my PhD
in chemistry from there okay with very
cool so shout out to all the cool people
and after my PhD I did a postdoc at
Rockefeller in New York and that's sort
of the transition that's well you know
the transition in my mind happened from
being a straight chemist to being
somebody who's doing more biomedical
translational work okay so and since
then so I was at Rockefeller after that
I was i doubled in a couple of startups
got some taste of biotech work
and decided that academia is a better
suit for me started now I was very lucky
to get a position at Mass General in
Boston and it's very quickly started my
lab there and have been sort of working
in a similar field since then okay
tell us about your lab lab people
currently yeah so I have a very estrogen
positive lab okay I have about eight
people in the lab experiment two guys so
we certainly are in minority very
interesting lab people work very hard
people have a variety of backgrounds I
have two graduate students for postdocs
a junior faculty and a tech and people
from all over the world people from us
people from Korea from Asia in other
parts of Asia people from Europe so you
know keep sitting very very interesting
okay yeah I know like people are
motivated these researchers are like but
how do you help them out because
research goes and ups and down has its
own path so how do you motivate keep
them motivated and get them going very
good question so that ship so you know
research really is a marathon not a
sprint
yeah so so you know for marathon I I
like you know my my mentors have
prepared me I have very my philosophy is
I I let people learn at their own pace
I let them learn on their own I let that
make mistakes and learn from those
mistakes mistakes are how you learn you
learn something and also we have a very
open system you know my my my office
door is always open so people can come
in and discuss anything anytime almost
anytime and we have a very positive lab
so very
you know people help each other almost
every project there is a leader of the
project but there are several co helpers
supporting that leader so that helps
that helps a lab and then we also do fun
stuff so it helps in Chicago it's very
hard to go out that night boy yeah time
we do a lot of fun stuff let's maybe do
snow stuff yeah that's good yeah like
since you mentioned mentors and all
those things can you please talk about
your mentors and how do you do the
mentoring for your people yes I think
mentoring is really what what academic
you know academia is all about you
really want to create the next
generation of scientists it's really
less about what you accomplish yourself
but more about the legacy you leave
behind so mentoring is very important I
believe I've had phenomenal mentors in
my life and I am where I am because of
my mentors starting from my you know
mentors in school to my mentor in IIT
Delhi he was my you know he's my role
model J BJ ROM he's he's a chemist in
IIT Delhi computational chemist and he's
he really you know sort of showed me how
to be a good mentor after that very cool
you know my my graduate school mentor
same thing what I learned about leaving
people alone letting them learn from
their mistakes letting them do whatever
they want to do what is in their
interest that's what I learned from Eric
and then subsequently Milton Warner at
Rockefeller and I mean Arno at Mass
General Sophie no I've had phenomenal
mentors and I hope I I you know all the
good things that I have learned from
them I imparting on my people and really
the future will tell how good a mentor I
have been yeah good yeah I've had I'm
also proud to say I've had you know one
of the one of the things I do do
differently than a lot of other people
is every
summer I take about three students high
school or early undergrad students to
come and get lab experience in my lab
and I believe that that's a way to get
very young people sort of exposure to
science lab science logical thinking how
our lab experiments are done how things
are you know taught thought out so
that's something that we bring in it it
really helps the lab because we get this
really new energy you know young kids
who really wanna they are there because
they want to be there not mom or dad
said oh hey go there no yeah so that
that has helped a lot okay and talk
about some of the projects going on in
your lab so I have really two main
streams of research in my lab one stream
is looking at immune system trying to
understand how does our immune system
work and then regulating it with new
compounds with you know discovering new
drug drug like molecules therapeutic
molecules that can regulate our immune
system and then a variety of diseases
that go in that run and then the second
part of the lab really is focused on
kidney diseases and there are also we we
look at interplay of immune system
immune system and kidney systems and
those really are two main areas of
research underlying theme is drug
discovery we want to make new medicines
okay like I have seen some of your
publications recently in Nature
communications and our so you worked on
lupus and you person a fright ease and
all talk to us about a little bit about
lupus what luper see is how does it come
about and what kind of autoimmune
disease it is yeah good good questions
in a shape so you know I'm going to
backtrack a little bit so we really work
on innate immune system in the body
really is neutrophils macrophages
monocytes cells that are essential for
guarding us
is infections helping heal wounds and
it's these cells that are really the
first responders whenever something
happens in the body and in majority of
in autoimmune diseases lupus being one
such disease in a majority of autoimmune
diseases these cells become overactive
and the last 15 to 18 years what we have
done is really tried to understand
mechanistically how do these cells work
how do they trust transit from bone
marrow going to through the blood
vessels and go to various parts of the
body to do the job they're doing and
then where does something bad happen how
does what is a bad trigger or how can
you control a bad trigger that could
lead to a chronic inflammation which
would essentially become an autoimmune
disease so really that's sort of the
underlying theme the protein we study is
a big surface receptor on these cells
it's one of the most highly expressed
surface proteins it's an integral so we
are really using that as a handle to
study function of these cells okay
coming back to lupus lupus is a chronic
autoimmune disease it is right now
absolutely in need of new medicine there
has not been any effective new therapy
developed for lupus in the last 40-plus
years it's a very difficult disease to
treat now it's and it's complicated the
the disease itself is you know manifests
mostly in women it's mostly in women of
childbearing age and it presents
initially just as a fatigue or a joint
ache or a joint pain and so it's hard to
diagnose initially until you know more
blood tests and stuff are done so it's a
you know it's a it's a disease that's in
a big big need and we got we got into
interested in lupus because the cell
type that we study and the protein that
we study those two are
critical factors driving this disease so
we figure that we can perhaps understand
better and perhaps make an impact okay
and going back to the immunity part of
it like various innate immune cells like
you mentioned about macrophages and all
so what triggers them to move from the
bone marrow to wherever they are going
what is the trigger that happens yeah so
typically in our body the bone marrow is
the factory that makes all these immune
cells and these immune cells have a
half-life in the blood so they are
continuously made and replanted made and
replenished made and replenish in the
blood and that half-life typically for
neutrophils is about you know 10 to 10
to 12 days for macrophages it's about
you know a month 20 20 to 30 days and
then they get recycle recycle recycle
and so they're continuously being made
and sent a century in the blood and are
and then they go into the various
tissues to really keep scanning for any
infections or any bacteria and viruses
but in the context of lupus it's it
seems that a number of patients a number
of people who develop go on to develop
lupus aureus complications have a
genetic predisposition which makes these
cells prone to be overactive just at the
smallest trigger so somebody may get a
viral infection and it may just trigger
this autoimmune response an over or an
excessive response from the immune
system some people may get this because
of some medications that they are taking
it's really not clear right now what
triggers lupus and that's a you know big
big area of research going on right now
so that people people can sort of avoid
those triggers it's not really clear at
all people don't know still what happens
and and lupus like I remember if I read
it right
there are some it is come as
it is a genetic disease and there are
variations of these genetic diseases so
can you please explain where exactly
what is the chromosome a little bit
about the genetic part of it
sure sure so as so actually it's funny
and I was I was teaching that to my
daughter
I school she's a freshman in high school
yesterday
so chromosomes are really our our
storage for cells chromosomes are what
keeps all the information in a cell and
chromosomes in human body there are 23
pairs of chromosomes that encode for all
the genes all the all the properties
that we inherit all our traits and there
are more than 20,000 genes in our body
as you know and again different cell
types have different proteins that are
overexpressed or under expressed in them
that that sort of gives them their
phenotype gives them their identity and
same for people our chromosomes encode
for genes that ultimately dictate or a
variety of our traits and and this this
you know this this this decade I believe
has been revolutionary for for science
in this field because all the new
technologies and tools that have been
developed to really understand what are
different genes what do different genes
do what do different genes doing
different cell types for two different
genes do in different organisms humans
chimpanzees mouse rat dogs you know so
it's it's very exciting time in a way to
be studying genetics of a disease and
and lupus being in here partly inherited
or predisposed due to mutations in genes
this is really you know I think it's an
exciting time to be doing that research
ok and like as you mentioned that is
these cells are activated and going to
different like it's autoimmune you see
slippers so like that means like Auto
and Ybor antibodies are generated so can
you please mechanistically explain what
happens when there is infection these
macrophages neutrophils rush to the
different places and the Auto antibodies
are general what is what happens
basically yeah so what is currently
understood is you do some trigger so
first of all lupus as a disease isn't
always you know what you call Flair so
people with lupus lead very normal life
most of the time it's only certain
periods in their life that there is some
trigger that leads to this overactivity
of immune system and that activity
period is called the flare and at the
time of that flare things just go
haywire and you know presentation-wise
then the people have fatigue as I
mentioned fatigue and joint pain and it
could also manifest in in skin
inflammation and in renal inflammation
cardiovascular damage brain damage
things like that so what what typically
people understand is at the time of a
flare there is a lot of neutrophil
activity that that leads to shedding of
internal DNA of neutrophils in the blood
and typically in the blood of you in
human blood you don't really find pieces
of DNA so when the pieces of DNA get
exposed in human blood other immune
cells B cells that make antibodies and
protect our body from pathogens they see
that as a foreign thing they think it's
a virus they think it's some infection
that's trying to invade the body so they
detect the DNA and start making Auto
antibodies against the DNA that auto
anti DNA auto antibody is a primary
signature in blood of lupus patients and
that's something that you know that that
gets that that gets picked up as a
serological marker in patients so you
have over activation of neutrophils you
degrade expose DNA out of them that DNA
leads to production of auto antibodies
against the human neutrophilic DNA and
then when there is a huge abundance of
these antibodies they sometimes cluster
form complexes and then this formed
essentially beads of proteins are then
going through the keyer through the
blood blood gets filtered through the
kidney and a lot of times these things
get stuck in the kidney for example and
thus induce renal damage that is
dependent on lupus so lupus nephritis
for example okay and in terms of the
mechanistic acts action these
neutrophils macrophages so they have
some proteins they respond to the other
cells like can you please explain that
part of it what are the proteins get
expressed how does it happen
yeah so the main protein or neutrophils
is this this receptor that we are very
interested in in the lab it's called C D
11 B which forms a receptor called mat
one so C D 11 B or Mac one on
neutrophils neutrophils are essentially
like you know spherical tennis balls
floating in a blood stream essentially
think of it as a blood streaming a pipe
and the blood being the water in the
pipe then these beads tiny beads of
neutrophils are just going through the
blood and then whenever there is an
inflammation this tennis ball which
where the the four on the tennis ball is
the receptors these receptors are this
integral CD lab and be these footballs
stick to wherever the infection or
inflammation is with that fur like
velcro so essentially this protein
targets neutrophils or macrophages to
the sites of infection or inflammation
in a normal setting and in the context
of an autoimmune disease like lupus this
fur becomes overly sticky for example or
overly active that produces more
damaging response from these cells as
make sense yeah and you talked about
seed 11b so they're supposed to be the
intake greens right integrity said yes
can you please talk about little bit of
integrins and their function yeah so now
again that's a good good way to segue to
sort of talk about integration so so
stepping back integrins every cell in
the body has a type of receptor called
integral integrins are the proteins that
cells used to basically think about or
or interact with their environment so
cells use integrals to interact with
another cell or cells use integrals to
interact with with the matrix or another
layer of proteins so integrins are these
key essential receptors on every cell
type there are 18 different types of
integrals in our body and different or
different cells express these different
integrals the integrated neutrophils and
macrophages is composed of C D 11 B with
its binding partner CD 18 and so this
integral also known as Mac one really is
essential for function of these cells
these cells Express the integral and
this integral mix helps them migrate
migrate away from bone marrow into the
blood from blood into the tissue it also
regulates by signaling by sensing the
outside it also helps signal inside the
cell and generate a lot of responses
that come from these cells so one other
thing i wanted to just say about
integrins is really you know that the
name comes the name was name derives
from its being an integrator of signals
so thus integrates its it's one receptor
that integrates outsides senses outside
integration that signal and tells the
inside of the cell what to do it also
integrates signals from inside of the
cell and tells the outside got to
in terms of the cellular response so can
you talk about those signals like
mention them like tlr4 and all those
things like how does it like these
integrins binds to the cells on this
surface right
there are other cells maybe endothelial
cells or other cells so what is that
interaction is about and what is the
signaling happening and what that means
to the cell like whether they are
binding migrating a little bit more
explanation about the signaling aspect
so typically for cells that are sticky
or adherent cells like endothelial cells
they're integrins are required for their
viability their integrins required for
this adhesion mediated viability of
cells that's one of the most common
things that is known about integrins so
in those cells the cells use this
integral to bind to their neighboring
cell or bind to a matrix and that
binding tells the cell ok stay alive in
the case of neutrophils the integral
that we study seat 11b or mat one that
neutrophils are not sticky in a way that
they are circulating so they're always
circulating in the blood the integration
is in a conformation that does not make
the cell sticky but an in response to
certain injury certain cytokine signals
for example from injured sites certain
concentration of bacteria certain
bacterial products or viral products
that then interact with a different
receptor on the same cell in this case
toll-like receptors or tlrs so bacterial
products or other products would then
bind to TLR on the same cell TLR
activation then tells integrins to
activate and makes else to eat stop
there is some danger there so the
neutrophil instead of just zipping by in
the blood would then suddenly come to a
stop to figure out what is going on near
this region where there is an increased
density of TLR ligands
and once the neutrophil sticks it then
secretes more things to tell other
neighboring neutrophils okay you guys
stop stop you know we gotta look at
survey what's going on here and thus
there's an accumulation of these immune
cells neutrophils on monocytes
macrophages in a region in the body near
a blood vessel where there may be
increased density of TLR ligands and
that leads to this adhesion and that may
also ultimately lead to a response from
the neutrophil in which case neutrophil
just sheds its DNA and thus activates an
additional signaling in the body so in a
way now bacterial sensing by TL ours is
then adding a signaling via integrins to
the cell to tell what to do in terms of
adhesion there is a second response that
also happens in the body which is when
the TL ours and the integrins are both
activated and adherent then they tell
the cell inside of the cell to start
making a lot of pro-inflammatory
molecules i want made our il-6 tnf-alpha
these are small soluble factors that are
then secreted out of the cell and tell
the surrounding cells of any kind
surrounding cells of any kind to really
be over vigilant and thus as you create
this pro-inflammatory environment so
tailor activation 11b activation at the
same time and and a lot of cell adhesion
that leads to this pro-inflammatory
phenotype does that make sense yeah yeah
so what once it is done like how does it
the cure like for example in lupus what
happens once the anti order antibodies
are generated they go in the lupus
nephritis they block the this thing so
how do you take care of it and what
happens and what is your work on some of
the agonist for these anti integrins so
so knowing what I just told you which is
in you know people now think people
thought CD 11b
and TLR mediated cell adhesion is
essential for the activity of these of
the pro-inflammatory activity of the
cells and this over activation leads to
these autoimmune diseases in the past
people had said okay you know what
let's just block c11 B and if you block
it then this response will not happen
and thus you would have a reduction in
autoimmune disease however a lot of
research suggested mixed phenotype then
in many cases block concede 11 B was not
enough to overcome this Pro inflammatory
signaling change that the cell is seen
so we reasoned many years ago that well
let's see if we just switch the seed 11
B from inactive to active conformation
without really doing anything else so in
that setting we we wanted to find out
whether it's gonna increase disease or
decrease disease not really knowing you
know what would happen
so we developed we developed a whole
series of small molecules then bind to a
certain allosteric pocket and seed 11
Billy they bind to seed 11 we change
induce a small conformational switch and
that conformational switch induces or
convert seed 11 be into it throw and he
said phenotype meaning if there is a
high density of ligands the self might
stick otherwise the cell just keep
zipping by so our CD 11 B agonist what
very surprisingly we found was they
actually act as a negative feedback loop
on TLR signaling in this immune context
in this autoimmune context in
circulating cells these neutrophils and
macrophages and monocytes in those
usually by getting TLR activation
produce more pro-inflammatory signaling
but when c 11 b is activated they
suppress TLR signaling thus reducing
autoimmune disease in general and and we
found now
in several mouse models where activation
of seed 11b by by administering our
compound and activating seed 11b they
can suppress this autoimmune disease so
we are very excited about it I think
could be a new way to develop
therapeutics against lupus and other
autoimmune diseases so you mean to seven
these are activated still they bind to
tlr4 but whatever the signal like what
you are talking about interleukins
coming out they dick they are not that
any more or less not correct correct
so typically chiyan are toll-like
receptor finding - it's like in like LPS
or other molecules induces this
pro-inflammatory signaling in the cells
and what we found is activation of CD 11
B really acts as a negative feedback
loop on that that signaling mechanism so
it really suppresses generation of this
you know Iowan beta il-6 you know these
types of inflammatory markers in this
context
so is it by binding to the same tlr4
receptor it activates certain different
signaling pathway or it does it through
some other pathway or it is just
interested Lila what is the like I want
to know a little bit more about if it is
known already yeah yeah good question
so we actually published this recently
in our JCI paper where we showed that
typically what happens a TLR signaling
TLR binding to LPS induces or or or
activates my t88 that's its adapter
protein in the cytoplasmic domain so TL
are points well yes activates might be
here it might be 88 then activates a
whole bunch of signaling cast air kinase
is that ultimately lead to activation of
NF Kappa B and that NF kappa-b
then being a transcription factor goes
to the nucleus and it induces a over
expression of pro-inflammatory genes the
second thing that Keeler does which we
we discovered was Taylor activation also
induces akt phosphorylation
and that results in degradation of a
second transcription factor called Fox
o3 and that results in in generation of
mode type 1 interferons interferon one
interferon - so it's just this TL are
dependent pro-inflammatory NF kappa-b
signaling and TLR dependent
pro-inflammatory interferon signalling
both happens in cells in the absence of
CD 11 B engagement the way I was talking
about and what I found is by activating
CD 11 B it really induces a second set
of kindnesses Sark and sick which
phosphorylates Sybil ubiquitin is that
ubiquitin it's Miley 88 removes it from
the from the signaling pathway and that
just changes all downstream signaling
and that downstream change is reduce NF
kappa-b activation and enhanced Fox O 3
transit to the nucleus the suppressing
interferon generation so both an
introduction of NF Kappa B and in n
reduction of interferon signalling in
this context okay so now recently you
had some good results on cancer right
like you are you are connecting the same
immunity to the cancer and decreasing
tumor growth and all those things can
you please talk about that yes yes
certainly so this is this is a recent
paper in Nature communications again
work with Judy Warner's lab at UCSD
where we applied the same hypothesis in
the context of a tumor micro environment
and and overall the idea what we want so
so just switching gear a little bit in
the autoimmune disease the cells in
circulation play a big role and there
they generate these pro-inflammatory
signaling molecules in circulation in
the context of tumor allora action
happens in the tumor microenvironment
itself where it is known that the tumor
microenvironment
recruits macrophages and other myeloid
cells from circulation and there they go
and they completely adopt a Protima
phenotype where they start helping tumor
grow by in using new and eugenicist
as well as suppressing t-cell
infiltration that could kill the tumor
cells so if this was the tumor these
macrophages go and form a barrier around
the tumor and that barrier prevents
t-cells from infiltrating as a physical
barrier as well so there are many things
these macrophages do and again C D 11 B
being a key highly expressed receptor on
these cells we wanted to see if that
would have an impact on this sort of
tumor growth phenomena and again very
Safra not very surprisingly now but
surprisingly overall we found that seat
11b activation kept most of the myeloid
cells in circulation it prevented them
from going from blood vessel out into
the tumor sort of micro environment so
you could remove this physical barrier
that was preventing t-cells from coming
in and getting to the tumor and that
that is has been a very satisfying sort
of you know research project as well
where we sort of said okay remove this
layer see what happens to the tumor and
then we very very quickly saw in many
different tumor types that the T cells
are now able to come in and recognize
the tumor and get rid of it so how like
you mentioned most of the cancer stuff
and on what is your fourth path forward
so what are you so one thing I forgot to
mention it you know before the start of
this is you know I do have a conflict of
interest on this research in general
which is I do have a startup that is
trying to take these discoveries into
clinic and again my my goal really is to
find new therapies for people so my
startup Adhir Pharmaceuticals Inc is you
know trying to develop these discoveries
licensed from all these research
universities where my lab has been so
the path forward is we want to take
these compounds we have now tested them
in a lot of toxic
these in animal models and we found them
to be very clean they're non-toxic small
molecules so and they are bioavailable
orally so we want to now take this same
idea
activate seat 11b using an allosteric
agonist and test this idea in patients
with a variety of these immune disorders
I'm lumping cancer in immune disorders
because it is an immune disorder so
testing our CD 11 reactivation as an
idea in these treating immune disorders
in patients we are here we are hoping to
get to clinic very soon with with
guidance from FDA and then really test
this idea in patients and hopefully we
make a difference so thank you very much
so it's really fruitful like I learned a
lot myself trying to untangle the thing
because I'm not an immunologist per se
so it helped me to understand a little
bit more in detail on what is happening
and uh and I hope the viewers will learn
a little bit more about the immunology
and the work then by you and from your
lab so thank you very much for helping
me understand the loopers and a little
bit about the humanity so if you have
something new you are free to come again
and talk about your new work so thank
you so much great appreciate that I
should be hated very much thank you
thank you